with the endless baby photos and
engagement announcements selfies with
cats and ranting statuses Facebook can
be really annoying but as we learned
this week it can also mean more trouble
than it's worth I'm Dina and I'm here to
update you on how Facebook may be
ruining your life it's the stuff of
dystopian nightmares a recent study
revealed that Facebook toyed with our
feelings in 2012 the social network
giant carried out a research experiment
that involved manipulating the news
feeds of nearly 700,000 users the aim to
study emotional contagion through social
networks they did so by tinkering with
news feeds to hide good news or bad news
and then see if it affected users
emotions so basically news feeds with
positive posts like wedding photos
vacation shots or thanks for the
birthday wishes guys meant that users
would be more likely to post happy
things themselves news feeds full of
only depressing posts cause users to
post depressing things or worse not post
at all because they were so bummed and
the fact that Facebook deliberately
affected people's moods without them
knowing is not only creepy it's probably
unethical Facebook COO Sheryl Sandberg
responded Wednesday saying that Facebook
can't and won't try to control people's
emotions and the company says that
informed consent to have your data used
for research is basically implied in the
fine print you agree to when signing up
for facebook you know the fine print no
one ever reads
we also learned this week about
Facebook's nearly year-long battle with
new york city prosecutor's over the
largest set of search warrants the
company has ever received the search
warrants were for the photos private
messages and other data of some 380
Facebook users who were accused of
committing disabilities benefit fraud
that is they were supposedly faking
their psychological disabilities so that
they could still get benefits without
working the prosecutors claimed that
snooping through facebook data would
prove whether or not their disabilities
were real Facebook has handed over the
data but it's appealing the court
decision saying it's an intrusion of
users privacy so the next time you're
thinking of posting a photo of yourself
with your brothers motorcycle in the
driveway you might want to think again
you never know when that can be used
against you in court despite this you
guys are still using Facebook more than
ever the world cup which isn't even over
yet has been liked mentioned shared or
talked about in your statuses more than
1 billion times that's more than the
Sochi Olympics a Super Bowl and the
Oscars combined Facebook might be
ruining your life but you're still
having trouble logging off so will you
be cutting back on your Facebook use let
us know by tweeting us at aj+
you